[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right you ready
luke and jake here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and today
we are going to one of the remotest
communities on the east coast we're
going to tangier
island it's about a one-hour 45-minute
jog across the chesapeake bay
and from there we're gonna explore the
town and get in our kayak
and we're gonna kayak to a chain of
uninhabited islands we're gonna be doing
some remote beach camping
surf fishing and just having some great
adventures you excited
this
buddy
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you made it
[Music]
so we're on tangier island right now but
we're not going to be camping here we're
going to launch the kayak
and head out to some of the uninhabited
islands that are close by
and that's where we're going to camp and
fish and tomorrow when we come back to
tangiers
we're going to meet up with my wife and
tommy and nathan and my sister
and then we're going to explore the
island a little bit and show you what's
to be seen around here
what do you say jacob should we launch
the kayak all right let's do it
the main industry here on tangier island
is fishing for blue crabs and these
little sheds you see here on the docks
those are for peeler crabs when you
catch a crab that's about to shed its
shell
then you put them in that shed and they
have these tanks there and they watch
them and once they shed
their shell and become peelers then they
go and they sell them
at a higher price as peeler crabs so
this is the peeler crab
capital of the world right here peeler
crabs are more expensive because you can
eat the whole crab you just take this
soft gummy crab
fry it up in a pan and it is very nice
the water around here is really
deceptive right now
we're in about 14 inches of water go
back about 20 feet back there
it's eight 10 feet of water
yeah little tiny birds on the beach
look there's a beach up there should we
go explore it gaps lady on it
well this is the first uninhabited
island we've come across so we're gonna
get out and do a little
exploring and beachcombing you find
something
what'd you find yeah it's a spool
oh some fun stuff that's a buoy
it's a little there's a little bowl
the old crab pot look at this the chair
yeah look at that big old feather
there's a blue crab shell
holy mackerel look at the size of that
bird print
don't get wet jacob it's a baby crab
well jake you want to keep on exploring
yeah
here's another deserted beach you want
to go check out that beach jacob
oh yeah all right let's do it it might
be a scary
cab on the beach
hey look at this look at this is it
wait this is not styrofoam look at this
there's
there's words on this i think this is
like an old tombstone
man that's white marble yeah i think
that's a tombstone bud says
in loving memory of paulie parks
october 19 1876 died
december 4th 1913.
life 37 years
nelly a beloved
daughter you know from the kayak those
just look like washed up pieces of
styrofoam but they're headstones
i can see some old pilings there like an
old dock or something
yeah there's lots of signs of old
abandoned equipment
check it out there's an electric motor
of some sort
the old pulley
my cell phone
i know what that is that's leaf spring
that's part of the
suspension system of a car i ain't
leaving buddy
a cat oh a crab there you go grandma's
big claw then he can't get you
you got him yeah you're a crab catcher
what happened here hold on hold on oh my
goodness
look at that mosquito did to you those
mosquitoes are attracted to those sweet
little cheeks
look at this feels like aluminum
it's not heavy enough for lead or steel
yeah that's some garbage let's maybe go
take that and we'll get rid of that
well jacob do you want to try to catch a
fish well this looks as good a place as
any to set up our tent
we're gonna see if we can't gather
enough driftwood to maybe make a fire
tonight and also
we're gonna try to do a little fishing
oh are you collecting firewood too jacob
well me and the fish are gonna be eating
the same thing today i brought a bag of
shrimp
uh for some jambalaya tonight and it's
also gonna be my bait
we can literally catch anything all fish
love to eat shrimp
only that look i got a fish already
well that rod wasn't in the water two
minutes and all of a sudden i got a
massive hit i had a fish on and i was
reeling it in
and it's gotten stuck so we're gonna
take the kayak out and see if we can't
free it
there you go get that fish
oh look at that the leader of my hook is
shredded to pieces either something with
very sharp teeth got it
or rubbed it on an oyster bed both are
real possibilities but
bluefish and of course sharks have
pretty sharp teeth so
might have been either one of those see
how much water we in
yeah we're only in about three feet of
water
what do we got that's a red fish right
there
little red drum both hands both hands
okay i have no idea what the regs are
for these so i'm going to put him back
until i figure out whether they're legal
or not
[Applause]
there we go are you are you sad i let
the fish go yeah
do you know why i let the fish go well
they have to be 18 inches long to keep
them
and that one was about 17 inches so he
wasn't long enough we have to let him go
let's go get some milk okay
like this here sit down okay is that
nice
hard to let fish go when you haven't had
any milk and i can't even put this rod
in the rod holder
they've been hitting it too fast man
they're just smacking this as soon as it
hits the water
yeah this one's just a hair smaller
beautiful fish
there we go oh i think the biggest one
we caught was that first one
you feeling better bud yeah i'm hungry
you're hungry well then let's get you
some food okay
all right guys we're gonna make some
seafood jambalaya here and i've got this
cajun spicy jambalaya mix i picked up in
louisiana
celery peppers onions
you want me to get your sleeping bag
[Music]
hi i'm
[Music]
you having fun on this trip buddy yeah
good
good weather good fishing good food this
is a good campout
hey jake should we get a fire
we need to make a marshmallow stick here
yeah
no it's good
it's way too hot jacob tripped and
scratched his leg pretty bad did that
hurt
okay you know cookies help
these are pumpkin cookies here
take one of these hey jacob you feeling
better
jacob's having a good time he seems to
calm down about his leg
and uh just checked the rod out and uh
we'll see if we can't pick up some more
fish
the wind's kicking up so it's hard to
tell but i think i've been getting a lot
of nibbles
the chance that maybe something small
has moved in and it's stealing my bait
all right we're gonna test my theory i
put on a smaller hook
and we'll see if we catch anything
man i'm snagged again found out what's
stealing my bait
nice redfish
nice little striped bass
holy mackerel the fishing's good i'm
getting a fish every three to five
minutes now
i just hooked into something big but it
drugged me across an oyster bed and
broke my line
so i think i'm done fishing for tonight
hot chocolate and look what else we have
oh yeah here we go
you cozy yeah well it's pretty good i
stopped fishing when i did because it's
raining pretty good now but it's bedtime
i'm gonna get jacob to bed and i will
see you guys in the morning
well it's kind of interesting night last
night we had a lot of wind and rain and
a big lightning storm came over and just
lit the tent up it was
it was pretty cool but i want to do some
more fishing man it was
awesome action last night so i've got
one more weight in my bag
i say we use it and see if we can't
catch something
well darn it my hook stuck again
check it out there we go
oh starting to rain let's get back to
shore oh yeah
oh it's raining
i've got some fun breakfast for you it's
a cereal
do you like it no i'm gonna i'm gonna go
and
and put some more bait on the fishing
rod okay
starting to rain pretty good again so i
think i'm gonna watch my pull from
inside the tent
yeah we're gonna have some cereal
ah there we go nice blue fish
well the rain finally let up enough
where i think i can pack up the tent and
sleeping bags and everything
but we got to get back to tangier island
because the ferry is going to be
arriving soon
and i'm going to be meeting my wife and
my two other children and my sister and
we
are going to go explore the island of
tangier next
all right jake you ready to go see mom
and explore the island
well our timing's pretty good i can see
the ferry with my family on it
see mama there's mama
see ya
don't worry buddy she's just gonna be
right at the dock
oh jacob's not happy about mama sailing
away
oh he's not happy
[Music]
hey guys
somebody was not happy when the ship
sailed
hi my dear there's a crab in your bed
that sounds about right
this will turn into the triple finding
the kayak
all right i got the kayak and all the
gear stowed away on the boat becca's
getting the kids changed and i
am sporting the height of fashion here
let's go check out tangier island
stop resisting stop resisting
you have been sunscreened so tangier
islands
not very big it's only about three miles
long by one mile wide
and there's no cars on it
walking through this neighborhood and a
lot of the houses have
tombstones and graves in the front yard
it's a lot of standing water here
so they've got elevated driveways
[Music]
there's a little blue crab right down
there look at
that little cat
oh
[Music]
we
well that was fun
hey guys did you have fun yeah awesome
well hopefully you guys enjoyed this as
much as we enjoyed filming it
if you want to see more adventures from
the outdoor boys youtube channel check
out our camping adventure playlist
and don't forget to click subscribe we
put out new videos
every saturday morning thanks for
watching guys if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button and you'll get
notifications thanks for watching